ce que la rage de roland ok est elle
justifiée vincent moscato vous êtes dans
l'aventuré dans l'émission c'est vrai
que ces quatre heures d'entraînement par
jour
est-ce que vous commencez à en avoir
ras-le-bol non mais c'est chaud après
tête en a ras le bol fait à l'aragon
parce que y'en a plein les pattes
maintenant après une fois que tu es dans
la compétition sincèrement c'est
personne ne m'a forcé à faire ça et je
suis content parce que le ce programme
sincèrement tu commences à t'accrocher
est en bataille et parce que tu
attendais parce que sincèrement si on
est éliminés comme anouar qu'un super
mec généralement son passage parce que
j'ai passé un bon moment avec lui et
c'était très très sympa après qu un pied
dedans
bon ben moi j'aime la compétition je
bataille et je trouve que et je trouve
que c'est sympa à voir après les
polémiques de l'action de laurent
ruquier
alors quand on est à l'extérieur
après faut faut savoir se moquer de soi
même si je fais une valve si j'ai pas
mal bien qu il le faut avec un bleu de
travail ou un pantalon de menuisier
automatiquement la queue de pie en plus
bon ben voilà après l'élimination des
noirs qui nie que la production ne
connais que voilà oui mais oui parce que
automatiquement autour de son c'est un
peu délicat d'éliminer anwar d'entrée de
jeu passerais tu sais que ça peut
soulever une polémique
tu peux tu peux te dire ils ont éliminé
parce que c'est un homme de petite
taille tu vas dire les français n'aiment
pas ça après a très bien dansé sur ces
îlots habillé comme un comme un brigand
parce que c'était le thème la première
fois que je fais le
ça fait une petite compil de vous et
c'est vrai que les regarder et le proche
dans la compétition
savez-vous espère une part belle à la
boîte à gifles moins de 35 la machine à
hématome 501 quand on en est à moins de
35 ans bon du point jean marc je te le
rendra pour ce parti répond avec mais je
suis là mon vincent je suis jamais loin
de ça va bien mais la choper le sujet et
cela bien sûr à l'isie vincent passer
devant la caméra que j'ai une crise peut
être quatre à madonna
je suis je morfle r je te le dis tu vas
pas nous le sommes aujourd'hui
regarde toi patrick parce que ça passe
vite
[Applaudissements]